hey guys new podcasts and it's great one
so sit back and enjoy but first real
quick I want to go through some dates I
got coming up passing the Ice House
February 12th two shows seven o'clock
and an eight o'clock no Dan eight and
ten Thank You Leanne that's why you're
here I am at Sioux City Sioux City Hard
Rock Casino the 17th of February Omaha
Nebraska 18th through 20th then off to
Vancouver for the Just for Laughs at the
Rio Theatre I think is the name of it
that's right the 21st and then Columbus
Ohio
is my call in sick to work show I want
to thank everyone who came out to DC it
was a sold-out show
I want to thank Brent Morin and Jason
Collings for coming out it was insane so
so if you're in Columbus if you're near
Columbus come out I will go to radio
I'll drink on radio I'll go right to the
club and we will do a noon show and we
will day drink and we will it's st.
Patty's Day so you do not have to go to
work so come day drink with me it's the
brand-new Columbus Cincinnati or
Columbus I don't know Columbus its
Columbus funnybone so that's it I got
more dates go to Barbara calm if you're
new to this podcast take two seconds I
have some great podcasts that I've just
posted and I have some even better ones
coming up so rate review and subscribe
to this podcast it literally takes two
seconds but it means the biggest deal
for a show like this because people word
gets out and it goes to the top of the
charts because you've rated and reviewed
and subscribed it and then new people Co
Bert's talking to today's guest who's a
beast it's um so oh you've done with my
read no that's what are you rolling your
eyes at got a text oh god who's the text
from good okay okay
today's read we were gonna try to
incorporate my daughters into it because
the truth is what
the our our sponsor for today's podcast
sent a very nice gift over so we could
sample the product yes and then talk
about how great it was yes but my
daughter's ate it and I thought I
thought it would be funny to have them
on the podcast it was funny it was funny
but is not what you want to hear no
here's uh this is an excerpt right right
here I love cherries berries they're
like awesome I like getting died for
them this was for me these are gonna be
for me so good and that was one more
flavor do you remember oh there were
yeah there are four of three they're 12
you're right you're right no no this is
this driving me nuts Leanne who's our
sponsor this week our sponsor this week
is Sherry's berries we got a an awesome
dozen I'm gonna have to edit this [ __ ]
down and that spiraled into dog barking
into it's just a [ __ ] nightmare in
two naked booties into screaming it was
insane but the truth is but they love
the cherries berries cherries berries
they've sent them over and the girls
love them apparently there's no stems on
them so the girls were losing their mind
you could just pop the whole thing in
your mouth this strawberries are super
in season so there are literally tastes
like candy wrapped in candy and they
were all gone by the time I got off the
road they were all gone and the girls
love them and and and this is great for
Valentine's Day which is coming up so if
you if you don't if you're at a loss for
a good Valentine's Day gift this is
where you go go Sherry's berries go to
berries calm go to berries calm BER RI
es e ER r RI es da calm calm yes click
on the microphone yeah and enter the
code BC and what that gets you is you a
dozen a dozen chocolate dipped
strawberries
1999 with that code but you can add
another dozen for only ten more dollars
so you can get two dozen really for the
price of like one and a half it's pretty
good yeah and there's four it's like
chocolate dip dark chocolate the they
were dark chocolate with chocolate chips
milk chocolate with walnuts and white
chocolate with chocolate swirl and they
were fabulous really yes they are picked
at the peak of perfection they are so
good they're juicy you know it just was
a great vet it's great pre Valentine's
Day
for me because we got it this past week
but you should go online and order them
now for the weekend do that right now do
that right now because this will avoid
you getting Saturday afternoon won't
[ __ ] I didn't get anything for
Valentine's Day just do it right now do
it right now order Sherry's berries use
the collective microphone use the code
BC and get two and you know what grab
your buddy and go don't worry I got you
covered
I'm getting an I'm gonna order one for
LeAnn and one for the girls and for
Valentine's Day and I'm gonna try them
love it they're so good I think this is
the first time you've been home for
Valentine's Day a long time really yeah
all right Sarah's berries berries calm
very calm oh I almost forgot I meant to
say go to Burt Cass calm and by a Bert
cast mug they're pretty cool I like them
they have two emblem the Bert cast
emblem on them they're awesome mugs so
please go to Burke Escom and check out
our merchandise today's guests
it is a I'm gonna say a pleasure and an
honor to have on the podcast he is a guy
that kind of revela revolutionized the
business that is podcasting he is a
forerunner in content I believe the way
he looks at this business is there are
very few people looking at it that way
and I will say that that it's the way I
look at it now
my first TV show I worked on the law
with him we're gonna talk about
and he's someone that I always wondered
if he didn't like me and it turns out I
don't think he knew me it was a great
podcast and I gotta be honest with you I
got more coming down the line I don't
know what mojo I got coming my way but
with Titus a couple weeks ago I got Joey
Louis J Gomez is coming over tomorrow
morning Patton Oswald Pete Holmes we
have some really big ones coming up but
no one gets bigger in podcasting than
this gentlemen it is my honor to
introduce to you from the man that needs
no introduction Adam Carolla
you drink last night
I appreciate you doing this man I feel
like I feel like our I feel like the
you've been in a weird way like um like
a instrumental part of my career do you
really do you feel like do you know how
you'd know me at all um no I mean I know
I know your name but I don't know how
I've been instrumental so uh career so
my first TV show I ever got was the ex
show oh the ex show Yeah right yeah and
so I and you and Jimmy were on the same
lot as us right and were that and if I'm
not mistaken the ex show was stolen
concept from the man show Wow sorry I'm
eating a lot orange yeah what would it
happen is is we did the man show as like
an ABC pilot and then they rejected it
and they went with the cupid starring
Jeremy Piven I'm gonna put together a
long list of TV shows that went on the
air before or instead of many many
pilots and shows I've done like
accidentally on purpose with Jenna
Elfman and stuff like that but anyway so
then we did the show and we did the
pilot and an ABC didn't want to put it
on so we took it to Comedy Central I
think and then Comedy Central wanted to
put it on and then I think Fox or FX or
whatever whatever it was wanted to do it
as well but we said to them well it's
kind of between Comedy Central and FX
and we just think we're gonna go with
Comedy said
trol and then FX went oh okay go ahead
and then they came out with the X show a
week before we came out and then it was
sort of like oh you guys are ripping off
the X you at least in terms of they came
out you guys came out first yeah
and we're like well I think they're just
ripping off our idea and getting it out
there first yeah which is smart I guess
sort of how this town works so I I never
it's weird thing I never give stuff much
thought I just sort of like all right
well they're they'll do their show and
then we'll do our show and you guys have
you guys yet
you guys had a distaste for the X show I
felt like I don't like that was the word
on the street when I got there they were
like because my friend Jordan Rubin was
a writer on the man show right and um
and I remember I remember hearing about
the man show and I'm we're hearing they
were taking submissions about for the
man show yeah and you know it's weird I
Jimmy's got a lot more that in him than
than I do really well I think it's it's
I think it's called caring or pride or
something you know it's like when when
we stop doing the man show and they went
on and did season five without us yeah I
didn't really have any feelings about
that either really no it's sort of weird
that I didn't Jimmy's a much more he
would have been a better member of the
Mafia than than me
because I didn't have any of this like
family or ownership or anything I just
sort of like well we did a hundred
episodes and now we're leaving and they
want to do a hundred episodes more of
the man show without us so be it
yeah you know I think Jimmy was more
like hey that's our show what are they
doing you know you always seem to have
like I always felt like you had the
perspective of and I apologize if this
is incorrect but I like I'm great I'm
grateful to be here I could be putting
roofs on houses yeah I had like
something yeah I had
some of that mixed with just look let's
show up let's get paid let's go home
let's die you know it's kind of like my
dad yes it gas tax right right and that
sort of was my approach the only thing I
really remember is during that little
episode when it was weird which was we
pitched our show to FX and then FX came
out with their show before us and then
they ripped our show off kind of thing
and then it seemed like we were ripping
them off because we came out second but
I remember at some point somebody at the
X show got a long shitty email from me
allegedly but the thing that was comical
is I can't type spell and I never knew
how to even email anybody back then yeah
especially back then yeah so emails back
then were you really had to be a
computer person to be sending emails
yeah and so it was it was comical it was
comical cuz there was just like hubbub
that like Oh Adam sent the scathing
email to whoever and everyone everyone
who knew me knows that Adam doesn't know
how to turn on a computer so yeah that
was that's the only really thing I
remember out of that time period but I
was just like well let's we'll do a show
they'll do a show and my recollection
was was and I came in late I felt like
I'd heard one time I'd done a radio show
and my name had come up to you and you
it's about the X showing you said now he
was like one of the good Nazis is that
well I never
you know I it's a weird thing but I
never really I what I say one of the
good Nazis I mean like I mean like there
is a thing in life where you're just
around and somebody like says put on
this uniform and here's a gun and yeah
you need to guard the gate so the Jews
can't get out and if you don't we'll
just shoot you and I don't really feel
like those people need to be blamed for
World War two that's just like kind of a
situation yes
you know it's sort of for me I don't
know yeah I don't know that I would do
anything any differently like I'm not
I'm not so proud that I would have went
you know what I'll take a bullet before
I I would have been like yes sir you
know and like if I was looking for a job
back then and somebody offered me a job
as a host on a TV show yeah I would have
done it yeah I was 26 years old I was
like [ __ ] yeah do you show yeah and it's
funny because we were all burbling the
same lot yeah that was weird and and
also a love line was on that lot as well
when it was on MTV so everything I did
was on that line sunset Gower Hollywood
Center yeah yeah Hollywood Center
studios yeah everything I did was on
that line at the for the first whatever
part of whatever career I had it's so
funny I feel like my careers mirrored
your career in so many manners because I
did the ex show and then did stand-up
and then when you left Loveline they
were looking to recast it and they
brought in Joel McHale I think they
brought I want to say they brought in
Kyle cease I'm not certain but they
brought in a bunch of guys and I just
randomly came into the road and I did it
with dr. Drew the first time I just did
it I didn't wasn't testing I just did it
to fill in right and I told the story
that I'm now famous for my machine story
I told it on that night to dr. Drew and
then all of a sudden my name got in the
mix for doing it and I was I mean I
would say and tell me if you agree with
this would you say that you on Loveline
that period of what was like 10 years
mm-hmm that you on Loveline on that rate
would you say that that was your that
was your sweet spot like that's the is
that the is that the best representation
of all of your talents and combined into
one I think that's a good probably way
to couch it I I I liked improv I liked
psychology I liked hearing problems and
in in in trying to solve them and I
liked discussing that with dr. drew I
I always wanted I always kind of um you
know I never really dreamt of being a
stand-up and I never really dreamt of
being an author and I never really
dreamt of being an actor or doing a TV
show I might goal or my fantasy if I
even thought about it back in the day I
guess would be just me in a room with a
microphone that was just sort of
blasting out to you know parts unknown
and sharing like jokes and wisdom and
and and doing it having a and not being
teamed with another comedian but being
teamed with just a thinker there's
somebody who had a base you know was
interesting and and knew was from a
different world than I was from and and
and had had a different set of skill set
and and so on and so forth and he just
dan just showing up in in my you know
flip-flops and sweatpants at 10 o'clock
at night and just sitting in this
windowless room while the city sort of
slept and just talked into this mic like
that that is kind of what I wanted out
of yeah life I didn't I never I never
really wanted to be on TV I didn't want
to watch myself I didn't want to have
makeup applied to my face or hair go or
go out and like you know pick out
wardrobe or get a fitting or something
like that I just wanted to sit and talk
into a mic yeah and I wanted people just
to be driving along their Highway in
their car at 10:30 at night just hear my
voice coming through the speaker that
that's all I ever really wanted it was
it was the I would say out of and I'm a
big fan of radio and and I think that
naturally leads into podcasting but that
period was the best radio I've ever
heard me and my buddy Lorenzo would he
was a photographer we drop off his
proofs at night just
we could hear you Andrew put people on
hold and go let me guess she was
molested right I mean it was the it was
I mean why did you leave did I leave
Howard Stern I think I there was a there
was a couple things that were going on
the last I think it was like the last
year doctor dr. Drew and I were always
sort of what they call favorite nations
we always just got paid the same and it
started off in one city I think and we
maybe grew to over a hundred cities and
as far as it grows you're making more
money yeah we got paid more and the the
ratings were really good everywhere but
they never the the the love line team as
it were producers engineers phone
screeners program directors there's a
really a fan of mine
they [ __ ] me no no they never they
never they didn't laugh they didn't they
didn't seem to really I guess would be
serious not at all not at all they
didn't appreciate anything that I did
going through the roof and they
literally just like I don't [ __ ] get
it uh yeah I mean they wouldn't verbally
say that to me but I'd go meet with my
program director like once every other
month or something and he'd literally
just say like stop talking just like
you're talking too much like you got a
roll phone calls you got a roll calls
you're taking you know three calls an
hour you should be taking 35 calls an
hour just boom boom boom get-get through
it like stop it
shut up well you're talking you're
talking too much you got to get phone
calls and so I would always just kind of
go yeah alright and then I just go right
back and just do
whatever I wanted to do and I think I
think they were a little frustrated with
the the fact that I would never do
radios about rolling phone calls like
get those phone calls rolling really it
is
it's about cadence and and I never
really subscribe to that I was just like
and and they'd be like you did one call
in with 17 minutes that's insane you're
supposed to be like 90 seconds max you
know well it it was interesting to me
you know or whatever parked waiting for
I would not be getting out of the car
listen to that one phone call well they
didn't like it and at a certain point
they said at the my last year I think of
Loveline they said look we'll pay it's a
weird thing I don't know why they I
don't know how they figure this one out
but Drew and I were both making like I
don't know nine hundred and fifty grand
a year or something each and then we got
to the the next contract and they said
okay here's how here's what we're gonna
do
drew is going to remain unchanged he
will get is nine hundred and seventy two
thousand dollars a year or something you
Adam you're gonna get 250 and that's
like really and they're like yeah and I
was like oh you want me to leave you
know and they're like no I'm just Pedro
three and a half times as much as you
and I was like that doesn't make sense
to me and they were like yeah well
that's that's the deal and I said all
right and then they started talking
about Howard Stern and who's going to
replace Howard Stern and blah blah blah
and it just sort of turned into that and
I ended up
doing morning's about a year later I did
make him give him all my money back to
get me even withdrew yeah when they
wanted me to sign my Howard Stern
contract I said I got a it's funny cuz
my agent kept saying you want a signing
bonus baby and I said no what the money
they owe me from doing a year where I
got paid a third as much as a guy sit
sat next to who by the way wasn't there
a lot of the time because he was like in
New York and busy and doing stuff with
Trojan condoms and stuff and I was like
I'm here doing a show Drew's on the East
Coast and I'm getting paid a third as
much as is him and I just want to be you
got to give me the money to get me back
to even with him for the last year
what's wrong with LA radio like morning
morning radio why is why is there no man
guess Kevin and bean or I've never said
when I laugh they said we want to get
somebody young Hispanic and funny to
take your place and I said okay have fun
with that and I don't know like I don't
know to this day if anybody over there
ever attributed any success of that to
me or the fact that when I left it
started just to fall off and it just
kind of it's almost gone away now or
something I don't know that there's any
correlation between me the success of
the show and then me leaving and the
lack of success of the show or whatever
it is I've it's never been discussed
I've never it's never come up did those
those listeners I feel like just
translated make sure you do you ever
focus on your numbers or how many people
listen to your episodes or why episodes
do better than other ones on on your
podcast um yes and no I used to I mean I
I would all read tweets where they go I
like this guy we don't like this guy or
what's this or you know just sort of
give the people what they want your kind
of thing but but you don't have like a
your own libsyn account where you go oh
I had seven hundred thousand downloads
on the first day oh yeah no we do but I
don't really tribute it to good episode
bad episode this guess that guess it
doesn't really seem by the way and also
it doesn't seem to have there doesn't
seem to be a direct correlation between
having Kevin Costner on as a guest
seriously yeah versus versus some
unknown comic in terms of numbers but my
to my best friends are obsessive about
your podcast and like one of the guys is
my DP so on the road he'd always put on
your podcasts on like late-night drives
he'd be driving and your pot your
podcast is is in the sense aim since
this bill burrs or is Jose it doesn't
matter who you have on people tune in
every episode yeah I I I'd like to think
that it's a little more about me and my
voice or whatever's going on in my life
and and that the the the guess is a good
thing to have and it's nice to have
reoccurring stuff and it's nice to have
guys who you enjoy working with and
improving with and stuff like that but
it's it's sort of secondary I guess like
I don't like if you like Modern Family
you like Modern Family and though
they'll be there'll be people that'll be
guests on it's not gonna make you watch
or not watch oh this is this episode for
me will be through the roof because your
name will be in it you know I it's thank
you I I know I can't I cannot think of
myself like one way or the other in
almost any facet of life I mean I just
it's like I remember I did the marriage
raff with Donald Trump and he like
showed up and he was slapping me on the
back and he was saying this could be the
best episode you you he said you
trust me wait of those ratings come in
you're gonna see this is number one this
could be the number one and I just
remember thinking why and first off I'm
on it how good could it be and then
secondly it was me him and Gloria
Estefan you know not exactly the you
know dynamic comedy trio and and but I
just remember sort of thinking like wow
must be nice to kind of be that way yeah
I mean it's not also sounds like a
little bit of a calorie burner but I
mean walking around everywhere just
announcing it's gonna be number one this
is gonna be the greatest it's gonna be
fantastic but I'm always just sort of
like well we'll do it and then it'll
just turn into something that we vaguely
remember doing at some point what was uh
what was what how did the how did the
podcast you are probably one of the
earlier developers of the bit of the
business paradigm of podcasting uh-huh
how do you how did you literally have to
sit and think that out there's and
there's weird things that it's like
folklore that I don't know is if they're
true or not but like is Jimmy a part of
this partnership is this jackhole now
still exists
yeah I guess I guess we do exist we're
just we're not we've been not doing a
lot of projects I mean what what
happened what happened I you know Jimmy
and I used to you know do shows and and
and jackhole used to do shows and then
Jimmy got a job in show business it was
like it's like one of those weird
full-time show business jobs that
doesn't exist in other forms of show
business you know like you oh you're
going to New York and do a play for
seven weeks but then you come back you
know or you go out on the road and you
do some dates and then you come back or
you go do you know we would go do the
man show and then we'd go into hiatus
and then we go do Crank Yankers are we
going to hiatus or whatever it is but
Jimmy was at his house yesterday
so you guys still hang out uh-huh I just
snuck in I like to watch him sleep it's
such an interesting it's dynamic because
he works full-time like and he's and
he's Nam I wouldn't say I didn't and
don't know Jimmy I've done stand-up on
the show but I don't know him but you'd
imagine there it's impossible for him
not to have changed somewhat
becoming someone who hangs out with
every of the biggest movie stars nightly
um and you still seem like like you know
that was the interesting dynamic of that
movie that you did you still seem like a
guy who's you seem unchanged you seem a
hundred cent totally unchanged so I'm
not saying that Jimmy's names changed so
I was wondering like that friendship
that you guys had during the man show
did it maintain does it are you guys
still like 100 cent honest with each
other is it you know it's it's the the
the reality is when we first met I was
you know I had no kids
I had no wife I had no life Jimmy had a
wife that he probably didn't like
spending a lot of time with and it was
just any excuse for us to go out and eat
lunch yeah talk about what could be you
know that's all it was like well we
could do this one day we could do that
one day
we both saw that in each other and now
the rally is is I got kids he's got a
new kid he's got a new wife and he's got
to get up every day and go somewhere
yeah and I you know I was at his house
watching the Super Bowl I was at his
house for Christmas Christmas Eve I was
you know we go out to dinner and stuff
like that but the reality is is I live
over there he lives over here he's got
kids I got kids and we both have these
crazy schedules and it's sort of yeah
it's sort of like life you know it's
like your buddy from high school and
then all of a sudden you get married and
then you move away and you know it's
like you still look at him as your buddy
from high school but you just can't
physically go sit and have lunch every
single day
you mean I would just go out to lunch
every day there wasn't anything to do
yeah and we enjoyed each other's company
so much but now it's a different
relationship you know he works full-time
I work full-time and I'm happy to say
that you know it's like my kids call him
uncle Jimmy and when we were driving
over to his house for the Super Bowl my
daughter was like this is the second
time we've been to Jimmy's place and you
know in a month and I hope Jimmy's got
this and I hope so and so's there and
you know it's you know nephews and kids
and you know blah blah IV its cousin ivy
is she gonna be there you know and it's
it's a nice family Jimmy's very
family-oriented I worked with his sister
and it like just yell heard some words
yes Jill and she was just talking about
him and I was like I never seen him in
other than the veneer of standing behind
it said he might a desk you know he's
super family-oriented and super gracious
and he's like one of these guys he's
just kind of better than we are in the
sense that you get a I got him like a
custom cheese board or something for for
Christmas I here's the things like me
and my wife are so much [ __ ] up that
here's the difference between me and my
wife and Jimmy and his wife yeah it was
you know two days before we were heading
or that maybe the day before we were
heading over to Jimmy's house for
Christmas Eve and of course my wife my
wife like announces we run do Christmas
card every year and then I have to tell
her Christmas was two days ago
well then it'll be a holiday card all
right and then we'll never take that
picture yeah so we bought a gift for
Jimmy G
has a barn that he just built and we we
did this I bought him this barn thing he
likes to throw parties he can put cheese
out or something my wife said look there
is a custom hardwood thing where you can
have the [ __ ] engraved and it'd be funny
for Jimmy's barn and you could put it
Jimmy's name on it and put it out he can
put cheese on it or whatever and I said
fine how long is it you know what's the
lead time in the lead times like five
weeks you know and so long story short
he we go over there and hand them a
piece of paper that says you're gonna
get this wood platter somewhere in the
future yeah with your initials on it and
then not the gravitas your hope well
like I said we're not we're not really
on our game but from him we get in the
mail I mean I got a I I think I got this
really cool pie the month but I get this
card that is like his stationery with
his wife doing like a short soliloquy on
how much we're looking forward to
getting this cheese board one day and
then Jimmy writes under it like hey
thank you for the generous gift if we've
not received it but we look forward to
you know blah blah and it's like that's
how much better they are than wheat we
get a thank-you card
handwritten thank-you card we didn't
then receive [ __ ] and we get and we
can't we can't even get together like a
holiday email like so he's just one of
those guys yeah like he's just I don't I
don't know where I I don't know it's
like you have to I grew up like a feral
cat like just I didn't look at people to
have to tell me you know when your food
comes don't start eating it you got to
wait for the other people the restaurant
who you're sitting with you they got to
wait for them to get their food like I'd
be like eating and talking it's using
the wrong fork and you know it's like
these weird things like then the woman
would
show up and you'd see the guy standing
up and I'd still be eating you know my
stuff with my elbows poking out and
everything and Jimmy just grew up like
with manners and civility and he's just
he's just more evolved or something I
don't know what it is it's a weird we're
weird combination yeah like his favorite
game to play is Scrabble and I've never
played a game of Scrabble in my life
because I can't spell I'm just looks
like have a hard time Scrabble
it gives me anxiety as I start playing I
it gives me anxiety thinking about
playing I've never even played Scrabble
yeah did you did you do when you came up
with doing the podcast and starting this
pirate ship ears did you talk to did you
run it by Jimmy to you did you guys do
this guy I always heard that he was a
partner in this no I I just sort of
realized that when the radio show ended
I'd never been out of communication with
my audience
whatever that audience was in my mind so
it's like yeah the weird way that's the
whole thing about like vlogging and
podcasting as you do it daily and you
start a dialogue with people who want to
hear it daily yeah and and so I've never
been out of contact with with whoever
wanted me to be in contact with them for
you know this had been now you know 14
15 years of non-stop contact and so my
feeling was is well when my radio show
ends all this start doing this just to
keep in contact with people want to keep
in contact and I didn't really think
about it much past that I just thought
if you you know if you if you are used
to listening to me then you may continue
listening to me it'll just be in at this
slightly different format and that that
that's that is it this is gonna send I
already know your answer there's like
nine questions I have for you that I
know that I'm not allowed to ask people
but like I'm still stuck on $950,000 by
the way um did you get scared when you
when when the show got canceled the
Maury show got canceled did you ever get
like scared in this business we were
like what do I do next like what if I
don't what if no one wants to work with
me again I did I well you know what what
I what I had was this see I had this
concept I always had this concept that
what would get me thrown off the air
would be some action that that I did so
so what I'm saying is is first off I
always had three or four jobs like
simultaneously yeah so I it never was a
weird it's just you know it's this kind
of thing I guess is a human being it's
like telling a 22 year old guy a man
don't smoke cuz one day you're gonna be
60 and they're like [ __ ] you home 22
I'll kick your ass
yeah I don't smoke a cigarette while I'm
doing it you know and you're like hey
and you know don't you really shouldn't
eat that hot dog cuz that's not that's
gonna catch up you know your arteries
are gonna in and I'm [ __ ] 22 yeah what
do I care
so that is when you're 22 you're just
[ __ ] 22 like you look good your shirt
off and it doesn't matter if you smoke
and smoke through a hot dog
it doesn't matter like but that's just
your reality and for me when I was
starting out it was like oh you got a
radio show and then you got love line
and MTV and Crank Yankers man show and
whatever and it's like my problem was
like too much [ __ ] you know - too many
jobs too much opportunity and I was
asserted in the mode of I didn't
audition or I didn't try to go out I was
just like you know mean Jimmy I'll come
with a show idea and then we'll put it
on the air yeah you know and that was
that
and so it came really easily I mean
there's a lot of hard work
but I didn't realize how much we were
kind of defying the odds of you know
nobody people that do late night radio
get paid thirty four thousand dollars a
year not nine hundred grand a year you
know they have to show up and prepare
and and have meetings and and deal with
ratings and affiliates and blah blah
blah and all I ever did was show up two
minutes before the show talked for a
couple hours and go home
and I and get great you know weird be
number one everywhere yeah and I have to
do anything and I mean I had to show up
but it was all like this super easy like
you know like people say you know in say
UC Davis or wherever Cal Poly will
somewhere you know they go you guys got
a 50 share like in this plate literally
half the radios that were turned on
would be listening to love line in I
know where it was like Merced or
something I don't marry you know I
didn't even know the affiliates were on
yeah I wouldn't people would call and go
I'd go where are you calling from and
there go
I'm calling from Rhode Island and I go
are you listening to the show and they
go we've been on the e been on the air
here for three years and I'd go oh I
guess it'd feel pretty shitty to the
Rhode Island affiliate that I didn't
even know we were on the air in Rhode
Island
I every time some would call from Sonic
Detroit or something I'd go
how are you listening to this and they
go you're on the station with oh your
honor so I know I'm getting pretty
pretty out of the weeds here but no one
life was easy like I just had job after
job after job after job and then what I
assumed as I assumed that one day if I
got thrown off the air it because I is
because I made some joke and pissed off
some Asians or something yeah and I'd
get thrown off the air and that of
course when I got thrown off a
a station that that station that station
that station would all be lining up to
try to get me onto their airwaves
yeah but what I didn't anticipate is
that the economy just took a big [ __ ]
and there are no more jobs so when I got
thrown off the air it wasn't because of
something I did it was just there's no
more money
like radios taking a big crap the the
people that owned the radio stations are
bleeding badly and they just figured
it's a lot easier just to play music and
not pay the the talent and just play
some Coldplay and call the day yeah and
so then I was out of a job and I was
like looking around and it was like oh
there are no other jobs there's no radio
jobs
there's no TV jobs like there wasn't any
there wasn't I mean there was you know
hey you could do a pilot for this of
that but there was nothing I did a pilot
or two never got off the ground and it
hold on you I was well this would have
been in eight years ago you know I was I
was like 43 or something was my age and
did you have kids at the time yeah I had
I had twins that were you know two years
old there's something and I was I
remember kind of going wow I got used to
this kind of lifestyle
and kids and big house and everything
and and race cars and [ __ ] like that and
I don't have a job and and and not only
do I not have a job but it's like the
phone's not ringing like and I remember
just kind of going oh what the hell am I
gonna do because I didn't I you know I
couldn't take a job in a radio station
and make one hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars a year that wasn't
gonna work I wasn't gonna cut it like I
needed a million dollars a year
and they didn't have jobs for a million
dollars a year anywhere and I was sort
of like oh what do I got to do now and
and so I was like well write a book
about writing a book and I was like okay
I can't spell I don't play Scrabble but
I could write a book and you know we'll
go to around do stand-up you know I
don't like I don't really have an act
you know I'm like well get an act and go
hit the road and so it was kind of a
weird scraping together of like oh [ __ ]
I'm you know Jimmy's off doing his TV
show we're not doing Crank Yankers or
man show or anything
the radio is all gone and I'm not sure
what to do help what's your wife like
during this time because you don't I
mean I think hair is do you guys have
the kind of marriage where you guys
could like do you like well it's funny I
was funny because I said I did know if
she's uh I don't know what she doesn't
her thing is like you know if I said I
gotta go on the road and make money
should go find and if I went I'm not
going on the road you know fine like she
doesn't really I I do remember this I
said to her I did like come home and I
just said look I don't have a job and I
got a huge monthly nut and I don't have
a job and you are gonna need to be a
little more financially savvy like
you're gonna have to get involved a
little bit here like cuz it ain't those
days where it's just getting paycheck
after paycheck and who gives a [ __ ]
you know like I'm gonna need some help
cuz I it's not formally it was none no
who cared like you just look you married
a guys rich
he just comes in but I don't got any
more money coming in so I need you to
get involved financially and she said I
am involved and I said you are and she
said absolutely and I said what's the
mortgage on this house and she said oh
you're gonna ask trick questions I said
I don't really I wouldn't consider that
to be like an outlandish trick question
what's the monthly payment on this and I
was beginning and then she was like oh
you're gonna be a dick about it that's
like I'm a dick
but I am saying I need you to be a
little more involved and I quickly
abandon that plan and just went into I
better make I better start making fun
some [ __ ] money
did you just set up one night and you're
like because the whole bit the only
reason I make extra change every month
is do my podcast but I would never have
come up with that business paradigm had
not I feel like you kind of invented it
you brought your oh yeah I didn't invent
anything other than it's just radio you
know it's just you you talk you have X
amount of listener
I mean basically what it what it is is
this you have a an audience and the
people that make motor oil or you know
flowers dot-com or whatever they don't
have an on space square space they don't
have an audience yeah so they'd like to
rent your audience from you the same way
you'd want to put your tire company on
the side of a dirigible and fly it over
the Rose Bowl you know like hey
everybody look up so for me I always
figured if you have an audience that is
something that can be monetized because
it's my audience that I that I have
built over the course of X amount of
years or I've delivered
I I have whatever relationship I have
with them they're there because they
evidently liked me and what I have to
say and I've burnt a lot of calories
over the years trying to make sure
they're satisfied and happy and and and
like me as a product and and so now I
can take that and I can say okay well
you'd you'd like to talk about your
motor oil or squarespace or whatever
it's give me a few dollars and I'll
share it with my audience
yeah and I don't think it's you know
it's right here
yeah it didn't know do you yeah you
strike me as someone who doesn't say
sorry very often III don't I will if I
accuse somebody of something and then I
don't know if I got my assistant mad
over there I do say sorry quite a bit
like if I say hey where's my stuff I
left it on the front table then someone
goes nuts in your car and then I'll go
oh sorry no you know that I will yep but
I don't really apologize for thoughts
that I have because I'm I don't really
say him if I don't mean them and I don't
really believe them yeah and but it's
not a it's it's not a pride it's not
pride related it doesn't seem part of it
it seems that you seem like someone when
you say something you stand behind it
III think I here's the way I I try to go
through life I think to myself what is
fair I mean there's what you want
there's what I want and I don't want
what I want it's a lot of people that
are like kids and the kids are like you
know I got twins and if you tell my
daughter look there's one sack of M&Ms
there's 20 mm s in it
take 10 for yourself and give ten to
your brother she'll go I want 20 and
your coat yeah but that's not fair to
them and they go yeah I know it's fair
to me and that feels fair and if I said
or like well just give him one she'd go
that's unfair to me no no it's not you
have 19 but and it feels to her like I
should I should get 20 because it's me
yeah my sort of approach to life is I'll
open the sack a M&Ms I'll take ten I'll
give you ten and then I'll give you one
more so you can have eleven and I'll
have nine now if you walk away from our
fictitious M&M table and go [ __ ] you
this is [ __ ] I deserve or whatever
I'll just go well I know what I just did
and I know that it's I'm calibrated and
I'm fair yeah and I'm not asking
anything that's unreasonable as a matter
of fact we had we both had ten M&Ms and
I just gave you one more so you got one
more than I do
and you can walk away and go this is
[ __ ] you're an [ __ ] and I'll just
go that doesn't affect me at all because
I know what I just did
yeah with you was super equitable and
fair and that's how I go through my life
I go through it without me being a big
factor in it yeah I feel like I feel
like I speak out of my ass all the time
and I don't think about what I say I
just start rattling and it feels like
you you and Joe are the two people that
I find most fascinating because you
don't need neither of you seem to speak
out of your ass you seem to speak with
intention I feel like I have thoughts
and and you know and I want to share
them with people and and I mean it and
that's why it's kind of I hate to admit
it but it's like you know sometimes
comedians you say something you piss off
this group or that group and they go and
and the comedian goes oh come on can't
can't you take a joke you know it's a
joke it's only a joke and it's
I wish I could say that but it's not
really for me it's not really joke I'm
just saying what I say you know and but
on the other hand it's weird it's it's
like you know someone will go oh go well
look a mom and a dad do a better job at
raising a kid than two moms or two dads
and everyone is oh oh you don't mean
that though right now go well yeah I do
it's it's not hate speak it's just what
what is you know and they'll go well I
mean I could remember like I had had gay
publicist and they're like well that's
that's your opinion and I went no it's
just what is you know it's not my
opinion it's just it is its nature you
know and then I would always say though
like yeah but I'd rather look I'd rather
have I'd rather I'd be raised by gay
couple than my [ __ ] piece-of-shit
bear it's like like for sure I mean
they're horrible yeah and so it's not
saying that there's not a million gay
couples that aren't better than my
parents or yours or whoever's it just
means all things being equal my kids get
a lot more out of have they get they get
something from my from my wife yeah and
they get something else for me and it's
it's better for them than it would be
two men or two women if you and Jimmy
were raising them oh well see now there
we would actually they would be better
off with me Jimmy actually certainly
would holidays would be a lot better
that's for goddamn sure but like do it
like when the this stuff about the
females aren't funny thing came out did
you feel like if I did that that's
something I would say and on a podcast
and then and then people come out me in
the next day and I just wake up
depressed in bed say that well I was it
was funny and I think that's funny about
it is um I was doing uh I still like a
long article for I don't even know what
publication so I don't I don't
err I don't I don't go get him or
anything but at the very end
just even the guy was talking to me
about comedy or books or podcast or
whatever and then he gets to the very
end and he goes it was funny or men or
women and I said no matter funnier and
he's like alright he just like took it
ran with it you know and my feeling was
is well I got an answer I mean it can't
be a tie and then the only alternative
is women are funnier than men and I
don't think that's true but I also said
that you know like Sarah Silverman or
Kathy Griffin they're funnier than any
dude I went to high school with yeah I
didn't say there weren't funny women I
gave examples of women I thought were
really funny yeah but it just turned
into something and I was so sort of like
well first off what do you care what I
think
yeah that's an interesting way well Iowa
I gave my opinion but that's my opinion
then you got your opinion and then he
and Qi have their opinion what it would
have how is this why is this a
threatening to you for me to have this
opinion yeah I don't get that I don't
get why everyone is threatened I don't
get why why there needs to be a threat
level for an opinion and also the the
people that came out after me were like
well Corollas an unfunny buffoon and
like okay even less reason to listen or
to give a [ __ ] when I say like he's not
funny he's a buffoon he's an [ __ ]
and I feel sorry for his wife and feel
sorry for his daughter and I'm always
like okay so then you really don't need
to listen to these super unfunny stupid
buffoon right I mean why would you need
like like what if I'm unfunny and I'm an
idiot then it's like saying I'm gonna
tell you you're bad at the guitar but I
don't play an instrument you know what I
mean like why are you listening to me or
why should the line gotta do movie
review
yeah why should you be threatened by me
I'm Jun funny I'm an idiot and I'm
uneducated and I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] so
what woody what difference does it make
yeah I never got that part of life um I
know we got to wrap this up but I want
to like I want to talk what I'm curious
I think what you've done in in this is
the thing that I I'm in therapy I always
talk to my therapist about what I want
creating your content making your own
content and being able to do whatever
you want to do I think is the I think
that's the future of this business I
think that's this is where everything's
going I see everyone scrambling uh-huh
and is how do you how do you create your
projects like I know you got the Paul
Newman documentary dude I mean do you
just like walking through the office
you're like hey you know what I'd like
to do and you kind of put it on Matt's
plate and then Matt goes like hey I've
got like nine options let's sit and then
you have like a meeting where everyone
that works here sits down or because I
can't imagine writing one page for it
but like no I don't know um
yeah because you've done two movies you
have four books right yeah you have this
documentary on Paul Newman coming out or
is it out yeah it's out like how how
does someone because I feel like I
identify with you I think a lot of
comics identify with you we're not we
don't like to sit behind the computer
and type things out and write things out
we have good ideas and we like to talk
and we like to do what we like to do how
do you do it how like literally I'm
almost like how do you make the cake
yeah I had this conversation with my
wife actually the other day who by the
way is so much [ __ ] hotter than she
needs to be I know like I really wanted
you to be married to like a six she I
think she knows she's sweet she's really
really nice person and but she's like
kind of laid-back you know and I'm like
look the only way to travel through this
life is to have I have this sort of
theory I mean I'll try to put it into
words here but you can sort of stand in
the bakery of lie
and just stand there but if you don't
pull that ticket even if that ticket
says 999 on it and you hear the guy get
on the thing is like number three number
three and you're 999 but if you don't
pull the ticket you'll just perpetually
be standing in that bakery and you'll
never get your [ __ ] cookies or your
muffins like but and and so everyone's
else's kind of approach it's like we
just pulled the ticket but they're on
number three and your sis 999 on it I'm
like just long as you pull the ticket
then you have it now I need you to pull
like 14 tickets simultaneously and those
14 tickets you'll get to the front of
that line at that metaphorical bakery at
different points as long as you have
enough tickets pulled but you've got to
pull the ticket yeah you've got to get
the thing in motion
so while I'm trying to get my kitchen
remodeled and do my next documentary and
come up with my next t-shirt design and
come out with my new newest flavor of
mangry or whatever it is it's got to be
in motion you got to pull that that
ticket and time passes quickly like you
were staring at that ticket when it was
$9.99 and you heard the guy shout out
three you'll [ __ ] blink your eyes and
he'll be nine nine nine ninety one you
know and you'll be like oh [ __ ] we're
there like but but meanwhile you have
all these other tickets that you pulled
and all these other bakeries that are
going on so we'll hold that ticket and
get that thing out there even if it's
way out around the corner have stuff you
know I just got a memory stick that has
fifty five minutes of my next
documentary on it that I took home
yesterday and it's like oh we're already
almost an hour into the next doc but we
were working on it when we're working on
the last doc you know like it's just
pull all those tickets and get it get
started and and and don't a lot of
people just kind of stand around and go
oh [ __ ] I pull the ticket I don't know
it's so far away what the guy just yell
he yelled seven seven it's 999 it's
[ __ ] pull it and get going and that
that's about it but pull a whole bunch
and get in line but getting a whole
bunch of lines yeah and that's kind of
it is this what you're gonna do forever
now is this is this like is this this
this pirate ship that you are and I
heard you refer to it as a pirate ship a
number of times but is this is this
could you be content doing this doing
your podcast don't you have like nine
podcasts yeah and then just doing
projects that you find paths you're
passionate about
hi how do you need something bigger I
don't have any I I don't think about it
really no I I literally this would be a
[ __ ] this would like where you're at
in life just to make your own content
and no one be able to tell you what the
[ __ ] to do yeah that's the goal I look
at like I go that's it I like it and you
know I don't know how to navigate life
other than to get up and pull that
ticket and get going and I have no idea
where this is gonna end I don't know how
much you don't have control over all
aspects of life there's horrible car
crashes and things like that you know
this has been good and it's been a good
ride and it's been a you know it's been
a lot learning lesson a lot to learn and
a lot of calories burnt and a lot of
wasted calories that I never really look
at his wasted calories just going down a
road that doesn't really have an outlet
and going all right well that don't go
down that road
and like discovering what things are and
and but I had bury cats whose J Morris
manager precast was my manager Oh your
manager and Barry just came up to me and
he's like what's the plan man
and I said why no plan and he said you
don't have a plan and I said no he said
don't you want a plan and I said no I
never thought about it and then I start
getting a little like self-conscious
like we have what does everyone else
have a plan I know like guys like Jim
Carrey like I cut myself a check for ten
million dollars and looked over I parked
I parked my Camry on top of Mulholland I
look down and I said one day you people
are all gonna know and I wrote that
check and I was like oh maybe I should
do
maybe Barry's right I should have some
sort of plan but I don't my plan is go
to work
half of Barry's things he says - he's
saying to himself but hey that said
maybe he thought that I maybe he did
what did you think he had a plan that I
could utilize by giving him 15% or
something but I just remember no I don't
have a plan I get up and I get going
yeah every every day and every day
something else and that's about that's
the plan
dude well thank you so much for doing
this out of a really appreciate it man
thanks Bert I appreciate being
appreciated
long
you
this episode was brought to you by the
machine
you